a roast is the hardest thing to do in
comedy i compare it to like
our olympics i i really feel like
there's nothing else to compare it to
you have to go as soon as i got asked to
do the roast i start writing jokes and
then you start taking those jokes out
and then i have to go
from club to club and just tell the
people watching
i'm like imagine rob lowe is here just
for the sake of things i'm about to say
really a lot of mean things about him
but
picture him here laughing and then you
get laughs but it's like
you can't ever really know how it's
going to do in the room
there's no way to tell and so it's just
it's so much preparation and then you
finally do it and
luckily it's always a great crowd and
they're ready for it and it's gone well
but the first time doing it i was
terrified
and i always um for the past three
rows the three that i've done i always
get to a point of like utter exhaustion
beforehand because i'm so
i've trained so hard and that night it's
just like it feels so good doing it and
being done
because you just never know what it's
one of the only things in comedy that
you can't really prepare for because
it's such a unique
performance i'm i'm kind of not
surprised but it's interesting to hear
that you
test or have the ability to go test the
jokes out which makes perfect sense
why wouldn't you you're in front of the
mic and you're doing your thing anyway
because like for me who i'm not a
professional at it
i i had never tested one of those jokes
that i
got so i'm literally this is the first
time i'm telling it the first time
anybody's hearing i have no idea
if people can think it's too mean not
mean enough whatever and it's all live
and it's in front of
everybody i know i always worry about
the stars during these roasts because as
a comedian
jeff ross me and you know usually the
other couple comics
we're all at the clubs all night doing
our rose sets and then we think about
the actors that are
our the that are on the deus and i'm
like they're just gonna
wing it but the thing is you always they
always kill you guys always do well
you have a one rehearsal but um
but you're professional so you don't you
can you always
you did well but it is funny that i feel
the need to go out and run the set like
60 times and i do see like honestly rob
i every single time i do a roast i am so
run down because i'm doing like
five sets a night working having all
these sheets of paper scratching out
jokes rewriting them reorganizing them
i hired a writer's assistant last year i
hired um
writers i mean i had a writer's room
last year i'm not even joking
it was nuts i like lost money on it no
joke
but it is like the biggest it's the
biggest opportunity for a comedian to
make
a splash and to really be seen it's like
we don't have the tonight show anymore
with johnny carson we don't
we don't have the same you it's just the
best um
it's the best platform for a comedian to
to make it so i worked i work my tail
off on it and every year i say
i tell my friends remind me never to do
one of these again because i'm losing my
mind and i
hate this process and then i do it and
i'm like oh my god that was the best
night of my life so i
i feel like they're like pregnancies i'm
always like don't let me do this again
and then i'm holding my baby i'm like i
love
i'm gonna have another yeah i mean i
don't have kids but i compare it to that